أنت تدخل مستشفى الشفاء
في مدينة غزة، هذه دقيقة واحدة فقط في
يوم واحد ولكن الأطباء يخبروننا أنها يمكن أن تكون في
أي دقيقة من آخر 16
يومًا، إنه مشهد من الجحيم، والعديد من
المرضى هم من
الأطفال الصغار، منطقة الاستقبال الآن  مركز الفرز
وفي كل مكان تتحول فيه إلى
ضحية أخرى، فقد أمر الجيش الإسرائيلي كل واحد من هؤلاء الأشخاص
بإخلاء
المستشفى بما في ذلك
الموظفين الذين يفوق عددهم بالفعل عددهم ويثقل كاهلهم،
ومع استمرار
القصف العقابي، يستمر الجرحى في
التدفق على الأطباء ويقولون إنه لا يوجد مكان
آخر يذهبون إليه.  ولم تكن هناك طريقة آمنة
لنقلهم إلى الخارج، فقد كنا نتعرض
لإصابات جماعية مرة أو مرتين في اليوم ولكن الآن
لدينا إصابات كل نصف ساعة،
لذا فإن قسم الطوارئ لدينا وقسم
العمليات الجراحية وقسم أمراض
الأمعاء الالتهابية لدينا مكتظون
بالمرضى.  يحذر ماران أبو سعدة من أن
الوضع على وشك أن يزداد
سوءًا بشكل كبير، فالمستشفى يقول إنه على
بعد يومين فقط من نفاد الوقود
اللازم لتشغيل المولدات التي
تبقي المستشفى
ومرضاه على قيد الحياة إذا نفد الوقود
خلال يومين.  أيام ماذا ستفعل أعني ماذا يمكنك أن
تفعل أعتقد أن المجتمع الدولي
سيكون جزءًا من عملية قتل
شعبنا إذا لم يتصرف تجاه
إسرائيل للسماح بدخول هذا الوقود إلى
غزة ماذا يفعل للشعب  الذين
هم في وحدة العناية المركزة وأجهزة التنفس الصناعي،
ماذا عن
الأطفال الجدد الجدد، لدينا أكثر من 130 طفلًا في
وحدات العناية المركزة غير المخصصة لدينا، ما يجب القيام به معهم،
سيكونون على ما يرام، أعتقد أننا
نسمح لهم بالموت بسلام، هذا هو
المشكلة هي أنه إذا لم يكن لدينا وقود لتشغيل
مولداتنا في المستشفى، فلن
يُسمح إلا بقدر ضئيل من المساعدات بالعبور
إلى غزة، دون أن تمنع إسرائيل أيًا منها من الوقود، كما
تقول، بسبب المخاوف من أن حماس
ستأخذه من
مئات الشاحنات.  ينتظرون
على طول الجانب المصري من الحدود
لكن الجهود الدبلوماسية لإنشاء
ممر إنساني مستمر باءت
بالفشل ولم يعد هناك وقت
للنقاش